Senegal and I didn't attain it so I'm not gonna set any more goal. Right? It's like no you set a goal
That was inappropriate. I want to own a house. Okay. Well, let's think about how we're gonna get there
Rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
What's up, believe nation its Evan I believe in you and this channel is designed to be a part of your daily success routine
So let's start your day off right together grab your coffee and sip on today's message set goals properly
Over to you Jordan B Peterson
also
If you want to know what Jordan and other successful entrepreneurs have to say about building unstoppable confidence
Check out my 250 for confidence series where every day for the next
254 days. I will send you a morning video for free to help you build your confidence
The link to join is in the description below if you're gonna speak
effectively
You have to know way more than you're talking about
You don't tell your kid
Here's an impossible thing
Why don't you go out and fail you say here's something worth going after?
Here's a step. You could take that would push you beyond where you are
But that you also have a reasonably high probability of succeeding at right they called that within a time frame. It's in some timeframe
That's the other thing you have to parameterize it with regards to time frame
That's right
And that puts you in the zone of proximal development and that's that's a concept that was generated by a guy named Vygotsky
He was a Russian developmental psychologist and the smart one
It's where the idea of the zone comes from to be in the zone and when you're in the zone
You're expanding your skills
in a manner that's
Intrinsically rewarding because you're succeeding and so you want to set if you're good to yourself you think okay
I need to set a goal
but I need to set a goal that someone is stupid and useless as me could probably
attain if they put some effort into it and then you go then you've got it perfectly because it's not
So high that it's grandiose or impossible that you fail necessarily and then justify your bitterness. It's like well I couldn't do it
Well because that happens to Pete how much all the time. Yeah, it's like this all the time
You know, it's like it's yes exactly
Well, I set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm not gonna set any more goal, right?
It's like no you set a goal. That was inappropriate for the time frame. That's right
you didn't calibrate it properly and
And you're playing a trick on yourself because you want it to fail so that you could justify not having to try
That's why being a victim. Mmm. Yeah, which isn't in helpful
You're still gonna be a victim like there's no way out of that man
So yeah, you know because life is this life is a challenge that in some sense can't be surmounted
So there's no way out of your problem, but there are certainly proper ways of dealing with it
Yeah
now I've got a really special bonus clip for you that I think you're gonna enjoy but before that it's time for a
Question of the day. I want to know after watching this video. What new goal would you like to set for yourself?
Write it down and leave it in the comments below
So I like to think of okay, this is the ideal lifestyle that I want and I talked about idea for your money, right
What's that have your money targets? And what's how much would that cost? You not right not how much you
Roughly maybe no, let's calculate that. Yeah, and what I realize is after all these years talked to so many people
Whatever the idea that they have they say I want to be able to travel
I want to be able to have to drive this particular car or have this particular house or this kind of lifestyle
When they actually break it down. Yeah doesn't cost them as much right after thing data
Oh, the ice most wanted me all in dollars. I need ten million dollars only. There's it rowing it random numbers
Yeah, because they said a number that's totally unrealistic versus Oh, actually no
I could accomplish all I want to accomplish with maybe three hundred thousand dollars a year. Yeah
Well, that's a very different goal than thirty million dollars a year, right?
You don't know you can't know how you're gonna conduct the war before the war starts
You can have an idea but you can't know fully just like if you were to say hey
My goal is to X in my life. You don't know how you're gonna be able to do that
Yeah
Because you talk about cuz you're gonna just gonna make it
Adaptations things are gonna come up things are gonna change the battlefield changes your life changes things pop up made things happen
so I think that that idea that you're gonna know how you're gonna execute something is is
Far-fetched I think you well, actually I should use the word idea. You should have an idea of how you're gonna do it
Yeah, you just have an idea like, okay. Well, this is what I need to get done
This is what I want to achieve in my life. Yeah, I want to make I want to do this. Mmm-hmm
What's the simple one? I?
Want to own a house? That's a simple one. That's a good place to start. Yeah. I want to own a house. Okay
Well, let's think about how we're gonna get there. You know, that's that's this thing about how we're gonna get there
You have to build your credit you have to how do you build your credit?
You have to you have to borrow money. Some people something they go to buy a house
They've never borrowed money before you can't borrow money
If you've never borrowed money
you can't borrow money for a house if you've never borrowed money for a car or a or a or
Some smaller object before so you got to establish your credit. Then you gotta have two years worth of income
Then you gotta have a big fat downpayment sittin ready. So there's things you got to do this thing
Good now now that might change across along the way the idea is that you got to move towards that goal
That's what was so nice about hearing
Vietnamese commander's intent
Get close split them up. Mmm. Boom you go make that happen. Hey, guess what?
You want to buy a house one day save money have good credit. Yeah, okay
Well, you got to make money how you can make money
You might make it driving uber you might make it delivering pizza
You might make cuz you got your real job with that support in your family
But then you need a little extra to throw in there
Well, that's why you end up driving uber you end up with whatever it is
You're gonna do you make your some money on the side that you can start stashing away
yeah, you got to fill your life with a
Bunch of goals so you don't get gem cuz I guess you have small goals that lead to the big goal, right? So for instance
You want to be financially secure and stable? What are you gonna do? You're gonna save some of your money
Okay, that's one thing you're gonna buy a house
That's another thing you're gonna pay off your car and you're not gonna buy expensive dumb cars
You're gonna buy cheap cars until you have the money to buy him with cash
you're gonna make all these will think you're gonna work extra you're gonna you know,
You're gonna do these things. So you're right. You have you have your broad goal? Yes, you have your long-term goal
Yes, and then you got your short-term goals that lead and are strategically aligned with that long-term goal raise your standard
It's
Not one drop of my self-worth depends on your
Acceptance of me if you want more Jordan Peterson check out the top fifty rules video that I did on him
I think you'll enjoy it
The link is right there next to me continue to believe and I'll see you there
If you're failing repeatedly, it's possible that there's something wrong with the way that you're conceptualizing the world